what
juicy burgers ferrari's pornography and
gift
giving reveal about human nature when
you wrote this
10 years ago exactly 10 years ago last
month june of 2011 which has been
translated to
korean and turkish interesting to have
been translated to korean and turkish
uh what's the book about and one can you
tell us what can you tell us about the
consuming instinct
about juicy burgers ferrari's
pornography and gift giving
right so the reason why i chose those
four examples there's a back story to it
so i'll explain in a second but
apparently speaking
the book is basically arguing contrary
to all of the social sciences which
presume that what makes us different
from other
animals is that we transcend our biology
right so typically social scientists
think
well sure evolution explains the
behavior of the mosquito and your dog
and the giraffe
but don't you dare dr sat apply the same
principles to explain human behavior let
alone consumer behavior
well that's completely silly i mean when
i put on my hat as a consumer
my hormones don't cease to matter my
biology doesn't cease to matter so in a
very general way what the consuming
instinct is about
is how to apply biological thinking
to understand why we do the things that
we do when we put on our hats as
consumers
now why did i pick juicy burgers
pornography
gift giving and so on well because i
argue that there are four
fundamental darwinian modules that drive
our behavior
there is the survival module right so
everything that's related to our
survival instinct
so the juicy burger example speaks to
that because
we've evolved the gustatory preferences
to prefer
some juicy manifestation rather than raw
celery right
patrick and i might disagree about the
type of fatty foods we prefer i might
prefer a juicy steak
you may prefer a you know fatty
chocolate mousse
but we both probably prefer some fatty
food over you know raw carrots
precisely because your ancestors of mine
evolved in an environment of caloric
scarcity caloric uncertainty
therefore our taste buds have evolved to
deal with that evolutionary
problem so that's juicy burgers
pornography refers to the sega module
which is reproduction so
many of the things that you and i do and
everyone else does
is precisely linked to the fact that we
are a sexually reproducing species so
in the same way that the peacock's tail
evolved so that he can impress the
peahens into saying look despite the
fact that i've got this very burdensome
tale
i'm still alive you should pick me i'm
the right mate for you
well in the human context my maserati
becomes
my peacock's tail so that explains
uh a lot of the you know and the reason
why we're attracted to pornography
is because it titulates our
computational systems in our brain
for sexual variety you mean i can get on
the internet now
and there are 10 000 beautiful nubile
women that are ready to
quote mate with me virtually well it's
very easy for them the brain to be
hijacked by this
alluring visual stimulus then the other
two
basically refer to two other modules kin
selection
explain why would i ever jump into the
river to save three brothers well
the reason would be because my three
brothers on average share half their
genes with me so if i jump into the
river and save them and even if i die
it makes perfect evolutionary sense to
do so so a lot of
gift-giving rituals that you and i
engage in with one another if let's say
you're my brother
speak to that kin-based altruism and
then
finally reciprocal altruism refers to
well okay
i would jump into the river to save my
three brothers but why would i jump into
the river to save patrick
he's not my brother i mean my literal
genetic brother
but in this case maybe patrick is a very
good friend
and he will reciprocate today he's
drowning in the river
but tomorrow he might reciprocate and
protect me
if if you know if i come under under
harm so what i basically argue is that
much of what we do as consumers can be
traced back to one of those
four key darwinian modules and hence
that subtitle i hope it wasn't too
long-winded
i love that i love that so you know i
don't know if you've heard it probably
you've heard this question
you're on a boat you got three people on
you can only save one
it's your mom your child or your
wife who do you save have you looked
this one up or no i have used the case
it's funny that you say this because
actually there is an exact same story to
the guy
the evolutionary scientist who was
developing that framework
it was based on you know i would jump
into the river to save four brothers so
so who would i save i guess i'd have to
do the evolutionary calculus well it
would depend
on whether you asked me this when i got
married if i'm 22 years old
or if my wife is post menopausal right
because
the reproductive sorry it's going to
sound coward
that's right the reproductive benefits
of saving her
depends on where she is in her
reproductive window so it's a
complicated story but the fact that you
ask this
exactly speaks to the type of
evolutionary calculus calculations that
we go through
so so it depends on what phase of your
life you're in so
earlier on it would be your wife later
on and maybe your kid
exactly and by the way your kid carries
more weight for you or less
depending on how old they are so for
example in societies
where they have practice infanticide
infanticide is the
recurrent killing of children they
usually will kill
the last born because the last born so
if i've already invested 17 years in
raising a child
right and they are about to under
enter the reproductive window of their
life trajectory
then i don't want to kill them right
because i mean
don't forget that i also extend my genes
through
my children having children right
because when my children have children
i am linked to them one quarter of their
genes right so this is called inclusive
fitness
so i can i could propagate my genes
either directly
i have children or by investing in my
kin
and therefore in cultures where you have
infanticide
you and typically the reason why you
have infanticide is because you realize
that
you don't have the necessary resources
to see them through to maturation
and so you make the very cold
calculation of ending if you want their
life
well you do so if they're two months old
you don't do it to a 17 year old who's
about to be reproductively viable
themselves
yeah so when i asked this question of
other people they by the way this was an
interview question so
and it was a you know trying to figure
out where a person stood and it would
many times
give a cultural answer because you know
latinos maybe they would choose their
mom because the connection with mom you
know americans
would choose their you know wife and you
have you know
a different asian that would choose
their child because it's future you know
it's very interesting
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye